[Music]
all right guys
bang bang i've got ed here with me thank
you so much for doing this sir
hey man thank you for having me on i'm
so excited this is uh this thing is an
institution on the on the
on twitter everybody knows about this
podcast people were saying
you know they can't believe you that
you're having me on i was looking at
your guests earlier you've got such high
quality of guests that you get on here
i'm hoping i don't lower the
conversation too much
you're doing just fine let's jump right
into your background uh for those that
don't know kind of where did you grow up
what did you do before
you got to bloomberg so man i i grew up
in south africa uh you can hear by the
accent uh i grew up um
just don't throw away from the from the
south african gold fields
um in central south africa and i came
i mean i kind of took the scenic route
into into financial reporting
uh i was a photographer so quite
literally the scenic route
um that's what i trained as but i i very
quickly learned that
i was into news photography and what i
wanted to do
was financial news because financial
news
in a sense is the realest news that
there is right
because i i know a lot of people don't
get that and they will roll their eyes
when i say that but
when you talk about finance when you
talk about markets
at the bottom of all of it is a number
and that number is real right sometimes
we get the number right and sometimes we
get the number wrong and
but there is there is a there is a
mathematical undertone to the whole of
markets and
and that's what attracted me to it so
that's how i sort of stumbled my way
um into into finance financial
journalism
absolutely and when you first started
what were you covering were you covering
uh kind of
all commodities markets how did you
think about kind of your focus at the
beginning
yeah so let me talk a little bit about
recreation to that so um i was uh i was
a reporter
through 2000 i was i was covering i was
covering uh
or rather i was a photographer covering
um in fact i was covering celebrities
and i was covering
uh i was doing paparazzi work at that
time right i was chasing kate moss on a
moped
um and then you know but i was trying i
was all the while trying to make this
progression into financial journalism
and basically what happened is pre-2008
this is something that people forget
pre-2008 around about 2006 we had this
massive run up in oil prices right
whale prices went to a hundred dollars
120
a barrel something like that and uh you
could see
the world economy being squeezed by that
now everybody talks about 2008 and we
talk about the collapse of the housing
market and
all of those bubbles in the us and i
think those those things were important
but before that the thing that triggered
the collapse was a squeeze in in
consumer demand
as a result of of of a pressure on oil
prices so that got me in
into commodities market so i was i was
really interested in this space
um and uh i got really lucky just after
2008
um i i started writing a blog on gold
and i
and i got this i got an invite on to uh
or i i joined a company called uh the
bullion disc
uh and they covered purely gold and
you know my south african background
helped a little bit on that and you know
i'm a little bit um
anti-establishment anyway right so so
interested in this sort of
in you know in in in the underpinnings
of the gold market
um and yeah that got me that got me my
break into there and then from there on
out to bloomberg where i am now
um and i covered i've covered gold there
now for about 12 years
um but i also cover broader financial
markets got it and so
you recently had this kind of mental
shift i'll call it you may describe it
some other way
uh where i don't think you necessarily
were anti-bitcoin but you just weren't
as
big of a believer in bitcoin and kind of
the future prospects of it
but that sounds like that shifted a
little bit so kind of talk us through
like what
how did you think about bitcoin
previously and then what drove this uh
changing of your mind
yeah so um i think it was it was it but
my roots i started hearing about bitcoin
about 2012 because
you know we had the first run-up we were
we go bitcoin was was just approaching
the gold price and everybody was talking
is bitcoin gonna overtake gold
so that sort of brought it on to the
front pages of financial newspapers for
the first time
which brought it on to you know into my
attention and then i had a
a very close uh irish friend who was
working in the office
and uh the guy was talking about you
know putting all of his pension money
into bitcoin and
and i was a skeptic i mean look but at
that stage
if you weren't a little bit skeptical i
think you were irresponsible because
it was an asset class that was vibrant
interesting nobody knew what it was but
you know we've seen some
interesting you know the south sea
bubble and all sorts of very interesting
schemes in the past so
at that stage you are a little bit
cautious about it
um so i i remember if people asked me at
that stage i said look
if i was to play bitcoin the way that i
would do it is uh
i put money that i'm not afraid to lose
in it
and then when i double my money i'll
take it out right i'll take i'll take
half of it out so
so what's staying in there is free
capital that i can i can you know i can
watch that accumulate with zero risk to
myself
um and you know as it were this friend
of mine
um who had his money in bitcoin when he
put it all in mount gox which went down
and he lost it all so people forget that
bitcoin at bitcoin as an entity has done
spectacularly well
over the last 12 years but for
individual investors there were people
that
lost everything so it was right to be
cautious at the beginning
um but over time as bitcoin progresses
you know so i'm sitting here i 2012
we've got to run up we get a collapse
i'm saying
i was fine it's all over this thing's
going going away right it's it's dead
now
except it's not right we can we get up
the the run up 2016
and what was that the second halving um
and we get another we get another run-up
um in
in in prices through 2016 through 2017
and then it crashes again but now this
title has gone a little bit more
mainstream i mean at this point my
nephew's asking me about it so
it's got a little bit more mainstream
people are aware of it but again if the
bubble crashes
and even early 2018 probably 2019 i'm
i'm writing pieces saying look
there is a risk of bitcoin literally
going to zero
and for me the reason is that it's not
about
the model of bitcoin right bitcoin has
proven that it is
anti-fragile it is proven that
you know if society collapses today 20
years from uh
you know a thousand years from now
archaeologists will dig up
hard drives that will contain
blockchains
of of some description right i think i
think it is anti-fragile enough to to
to really be sustainable and i thought
that even then
what i didn't know what i wasn't sure of
and what what
made it a less viable mainstream
investment for me
was the fact that it was
what hadn't been proven is the demand
side of it this is the supply side was
beautifully designed the demand side
usually when you see a bubble and you
see a collapse
in an asset that is that derives its
value
purely from a network effect you
usually see a complete collapse in the
underlying
right it goes to you now
when i saw that happen the first time i
thought okay that's fine the second time
okay that's fine
when something that you do not expect
happens three times in a row
you've got to start adjusting your
assumptions and that's where i am now
because now what has been proven to me
is that
the demand side for bitcoin is as
maybe not as stable as the supply side
the supply side is is
is durable the the demand side is is
quite
durable it has been for 12 years it's
proven that it can sustain
several cycles and i think that's why
many financial analysts are
are addressing their their view
yeah and in terms of bitcoin today
obviously a lot of people are comparing
it to gold right and kind of this
digital gold narrative
i think it's really interesting that you
had this uh framework where it was like
look the supply side is
programmatic it's transparent it's kind
of beautifully designed as you described
uh the demand side was um kind of the
question
and so if we zoom out a little bit uh
we're obviously
in a pandemic-induced kind of economic
crisis if you will and there's been
government intervention there's been all
sorts of interest rate manipulation and
quantitative easing
do you think that the confidence that
you have in the demand
is driven by that macro environment
really pushing people to like inflation
hedge assets
or do you think it's something else that
has kind of opened your eyes to where
that demand
um is and will be in the future yeah i
think i think i think we're getting into
that
territory of of sort of gold versus
bitcoin and i think
it is a very interesting question right
because
bitcoin has been set up to model gold
on the supply side and at the same time
has been is a reaction
to the fears about fiat currency
but there are big big differences
between gold and bitcoin right
um the first the first that i would
highlight is
is that there are differences in
how bitcoin acts at the moment
to how gold acts so let's say let's say
i am a
i'm either you know i'm a professional
investor or i'm investing my own money
right i've got a portfolio of assets
that i expect
to act a certain way and
if i have gold in there now it does a
certain job it has a certain volatility
it has a certain correlation to other
assets
uh it you know it it it acts as a risk
on
a rather risk off play
if i yank out the gold and i put in
bitcoin bitcoin does a
completely different job bitcoin is much
more volatile
it is much it's correlation to other
assets it's
a lot different and it's a lot more risk
on
than gold is so so just yanking out one
and putting in the other one i
even though the debate is set up that
way i don't think that's how most people
i don't i there are certainly some
people we've both spoken to people on
twitter that have said this right i've
sold all my gold and i've gone into
bitcoin
and i think that's fair enough and and
this is probably people that that owned
quite substantial part of their holdings
was in gold so they had a certain
expectation for it
and if you are you are you are awaiting
the collapse of the dollar
system then that is something that makes
sense but if you are a
pension fund manager then that's not how
you look at
how you look at your assets um and i
think
there are other there are other things
that they have in
common there are other commonalities
between between gold and bitcoin
bitcoin there's one thing people forget
about gold is that the supply side is
almost perfectly
inelastic right um
if there's a spike in demand for gold
you don't it's a little bit comes from
the recycling market but for the most
part
the supplier above ground supply stays
stable and what is there at what is out
there
that doesn't change which is which makes
it quite a unique asset but that's
something that
that bitcoin does as well uh it's it's
you know it's it's supply stays stable
through spikes and that's why you see
these big movements in price
the other the other two things i'd like
to highlight with that they have in
common
is that they quite poor
oh the bitcoin the bitcoin guys are
going to hate me for this but they are
quite they
they're not great units of exchange
right at this moment
people don't tend to use them for
transactions
we saw in 2017 that the network
buckled under it and the same for gold
you know you don't spend your gold right
you
you use it as a store
of wealth the the other main thing that
they have in common is that
both of them are very blind goods
right so a normal good if the price of
the
the underlying goes up people buy less
of it
yeah a veteran good if the
price of the underlying goes up people
get excited
and they buy more right we steve
this in 2017 with bitcoin
we see it in 2020 with gold price goes
up being on the front page
and the retail investor is suddenly
saying hey look at gold gold's going up
and there's they start
buying it so so you know um i think
that's those are the things that they
have in common
so you know that makes it that makes it
very interesting
but when we start talking about this
idea of a store of wealth
which is the big selling point that i
that i hear being pushed for bitcoin at
the moment
what is this what is the store of wealth
store of wealth is something that
you buy with the expectation
that it will keep its value in real
terms
right before inflate or after inflation
it buys the same amount as it did
yesterday nobody's making that argument
about bitcoin right
people are saying bitcoin is going up
now something that's going
up in value it's not a bad place to put
your wealth
it's not a bad place to store your
wealth but that's not what we understand
with the store of wealth right
a store of wealth is something slightly
different you know this i'm not telling
you anything new
but i just i kind of want to explain
where my
thought process comes from right and and
how how i see them
um so real quick
is it fair to say that uh your thought
process here
is gold is uh much more of a store of
wealth type asset
and bitcoin is much more of a asymmetric
type asset
is that a fair characterization of kind
of how you think about the two assets
yeah i think so i think so i think i
think bitcoin is
uh so so your potential upside in
bitcoin is spectacular which it is not
in gold right
in gold gold's not a great store of
wealth either because it because it
fluctuates
uh really treasury you know
inflation-adjusted treasuries
is kind of the only thing out there or
maybe oil oil is a better you know buy a
barrel of oil and
store it for five years you will have a
much better read on inflation
generally but i think
i think the way that i think bitcoin is
is is um bitcoin's slightly different
um right now bitcoin is a speculative
play
on the hope that it will someday be
gold on the hope that it will someday be
and i think
that's valid i think it's an important
but if you if you're a fund manager or
if you're buying shares for your own
account or whatever right
and you spot this new up-and-coming
company right
and you think this i mean they you know
what they market you know the annual
turnover now is uh
100 million or something you're saying
someday this company company's going to
kill
apple right where does that fit in your
portfolio
do you sell all of your apple shares and
buy this company
you don't do you what you do is you
go you go sell some of these other
venture cap
speculative assets and that's where it
sits and that's what i'm saying i'm
saying
that in a well-designed portfolio
that uh you know with with various
caveats if you are the person that that
has a long enough time frame blah blah
blah
both gold and bitcoin has a space in
your portfolio and they split in very
different places
they do very different things you need
to understand what both of them do
but right now i didn't used to think so
six months ago a year ago i did not
think that bitcoin was a
viable asset for a reta for a for a
private investor
approaching his pension today i think
one percent two percent three percent
why not right
i'll tell you what i used to think that
bitcoin was
like a lottery ticket i could throw
money in there
and lose it all and the upsides
potentially spectacular
now i know if
if i hear somebody's buying lottery
tickets i'd be like
what are you doing put your money in
bitcoin instead because because if
you're gonna you know
that speculative money that money that
you're hoping
is gonna pay off massive
someday that should really be encrypted
yeah i love the framework that you use
let's talk about um kind of the macro
environment moving into 2021 and kind of
the outlook for both gold and bitcoin
how do you view maybe let's say the
federal reserve and other central banks
around the world are they going to keep
printing money and injecting liquidity
and how do these inflation hedge assets
work oh man like they've got a choice
right
i mean you know they they've not got a
tort choice
there is no way that that that the
central banks
are able to let the companies fail that
are ready to fail at this
point right there's no way that that the
central banks could just say look
we so i don't think there's any question
about it
uh the the eurozone
it feels trapped um it feels trapped in
negative rates i don't see
where they're coming out um but you know
at the same time uh have you looked at a
long-term
chart of uh 30-year treasury yields
right
the the the progression since the 1970s
yields have been falling and falling and
falling
ray dalio is another guy that's big on
gold big on bitcoin
um these days big on bitcoin but i mean
he's changed his mind
um and i think the reason is that they
are realizing that
yields can only go so low right
and quantitative easing is a trap that
people can't get out of
it's really it's a hard one i so the
macro environment is difficult i do
think that going into 2021
you know we're at the bottom of an
economic cycle we must be because
you can't you can't imagine a bigger
economic contraction than the one we had
and what do you what's historically
what's been the best thing mainstream
asset
to buy at the bottom of a economic cycle
it's stocks
there's always been stocks right you buy
stocks at the bottom of the cycle
you wait until we get light cycle and
then you get into your bones i mean
if you are somebody with perfect
foresight and blah blah
but that's difficult um so i think i
think in the near-term macro
cycle yeah i think we spend we spend a
higher from here on out
but i but i do think that the central
banks have put them they've
given themselves an interesting trap um
now inflation which you brought up
whether the whether the market
market-based measures
and the um
and the official cpi you know
inflation readings whether those are
correct that's
that's an entirely different different
question right i mean things like house
prices are not included in there
and i don't know about you but my
accommodation
is my biggest monthly expense so leaving
that out of the equation
makes no sense um but we're at an
interesting point there's
this what's the old saying you know um
by when there's blood in the streets
it's a bit crude it's a bit crude it
feels a bit crude today especially but
but i but i do think that right now
this is the moment that the future ray
dalios the future
hedge fund superstars the future
billionaires by that point probably
trillionaires
you know that generation is being
created
today the guys who make the good calls
today they are the ones that we're going
to be talking
about 10 years and 20 years from now
i i couldn't agree more uh it's really
funny i just went and looked at
a a friend of mine or somebody i know on
twitter uh charlie
bolello i think is he pronouncing that
yeah uh posted this chart and it was
basically the
10-year uh returns of different asset
classes you mentioned about stocks
the u.s small cap stocks basically
returned it was like 10.9 percent
compounded annually for the last decade
the u.s large caps uh compounded at
about 13
and then the nasdaq 100 compounded at 20
right for a whole decade so all three of
those sound pretty good
but then when you look at bitcoin
bitcoin was compounding at over 200
percent
yeah for a decade and so i think that
it's really interesting when you start
to kind of compare
um you know equity-like uh returns but
basically on steroids
with something like gold which only
compounded at about 2.2 percent
annually yeah right and so it's kind of
this idea
of how much of past performance will we
see
in future performance right and how
indicative is that
versus uh kind of the belief that uh hey
the quote-unquote returns in u.s dollar
value
have already been captured by those that
were early and uh and basically from
here on out
you know it just goes flat um i tend to
think that's not gonna happen but
definitely an argument that some people
are making yeah
and i think i think that's why that's
why the wider investment community is
picking up on this uh we at bloomberg
we are definitely covering more
bitcoin a lot more because our
readership wanted
right the investment funds they are
starting to realize that it's
never going to go away they're looking
at these returns they are salivating
because they you know they can't have
owning bonds at this stage you're saying
i'm getting
zero yield how where am i expecting
those yields to fall too so
i'm looking for alternative assets um
and they are looking to gold and they
are looking to bitcoin and they are
looking to
venture cap and spax and all sorts of
you know
but i can ask you a question sure you
know the debate the debate about uh the
bitcoin versus blockchain
right so so should i be in blockchain
companies as opposed to in bitcoin
where do you stand on that do you think
that bitcoin is
the ultimate use case yeah well so i
think there's
uh a little bit of a nuance to this
conversation so uh there's bitcoin
there's what i'll call blockchain uh or
protocol based
uh product services and then there's the
infrastructure
companies right and so where i've chosen
to invest capital
uh and raised money into funds and went
and deployed
you know over 100 million dollars is
this idea of uh
putting a very material percentage
double-digit percentage into bitcoin
specifically
uh and then taking the balance of those
funds
uh and investing in the equity of the
infrastructure companies
right so you can think of it as
investing in
exchanges like you know coinbase or uh
kind of financial product companies like
block fi
kind of payment processors like zap with
their product strike
those types of businesses right but
again the idea here is you want to
basically get exposure to an entire
ecosystem and so
having direct exposure to bitcoin the
way that i think of bitcoin
and basically we talked about it to uh
you know we've got public pensions that
uh rlps in our fund and kind of very
conservative type investors
was look yes you can go speculate on the
price
of uh an asset a currency rate like
bitcoin but
that would be like speculating on the
price of the us dollar the euro the end
whatever
but the way i view it is those investors
are actually getting exposure
to bitcoin the payment system and if you
think of you know the
uh the annualized uh or annual
transaction volume on the bitcoin
network
it was more than paypal venmo or apple
pay did last year
right so last year bitcoin was used more
from a transaction volume standpoint
uh than those three products now if i
want to own
paypal right the payment system i go buy
paypal stock right if i want to own
amazon aws i go buy amazon stock or
facebook social graph i go by facebook
stock
but if i want to own the bitcoin network
there's no stock to go buy there's no
centralized
uh kind of organization and so instead
what i've got to do is i've got to buy
bitcoin the asset
because as demand increases the price of
that individual
asset will rise right so there's some
some causation there
and so i think that becomes a really
interesting um
kind of new framework when you get into
these like decentralized products or
decentralized organizations
and so bitcoin by far is the winner no
one's going to compete with bitcoin i
think when it comes to
kind of decentralized um and separation
of state and money
and i think that's going to be the
foregone you know conclusion or winner
there
now there's taking those same principles
of decentralization i think you're going
to see decentralization
across the spectrum what scares me a
little bit
in kind of you know d5 and some of this
other stuff is there's a lot of
financial engineering going on
and so it remains to be seen how
sustainable are the current iterations
some of them will succeed some of them
will follow the wayside just like you
saw
uh you know many other market cycles uh
so it'll be interesting to kind of see
how this plays out but i think
my highest conviction you know idea is
really bitcoin and so i've chosen to put
you know majority of my net worth there
and also invest a lot on behalf of
our investors as well
i'll tell you this um the the idea
we didn't really talk about the network
effect the network effect i mean that is
effectively what i was talking about
the the the demand side of bitcoin that
is
to me is the it's the network effect and
uh there's this saying in the
bitcoin community that it happens slowly
and then all at once
and it it was a bit like that for me
because my my initial turning point was
when i went to
i was invited to speak at a conference
on bitcoin in malta
um malta delta right spoken
malta delta and i went out there
and the i met cz at finance
uh and i met uh i met nick sabo but
i didn't meet him there i met him
somewhere else anyway the point is
i sat i sat in that room with the people
and i was like
the amount of human ingenuity that is
being poured
into this it's clearly clearly these
people are staking their
lives on it right their careers their
livelihoods
it it's a high conviction trade for
these people i was like
clearly they are seeing something that i
am not dismissing it at this stage
feels foolish and then shortly after
that we had the collapse in prices i
think
um i might have got the timeline
slightly wrong there but you know so if
somebody i know what the internet's like
and somebody's going to check me up like
ah malta was before or after the crashes
you know it's like
but but um and i think that's where i am
now i think i think
i bitcoin if you allocate to this space
bitcoin is by far the front runner it's
the strongest it's got the network
getting it being overtaken is going to
be really hard
so i think for most people
whatever they decide to allocate the
majority should be bitcoin
and the rest should be split between
whether it's your front or
my coins or whether it is you know with
a massive caveat that this is not
financial advice and you've got to first
decide whether bitcoin is right for you
for your uh portfolio what your you know
how much money you have and
when you're retiring and all of those
things but yeah no i think we see eye to
eye so this is um this has been really
useful to me
absolutely let's look at uh kind of 2021
and beyond what do you think happens to
uh
gold and what do you think happens to
bitcoin uh gold is
gold gold's gonna have a tough time i
feel like so i think so i think
i think gold had such a fantastic run-up
um
and you know you could see it squeeze uh
i i started turning
because i'm not um i
you know i i turned bullish
the run-up in gold's probably might have
been my best financial call ever i'm
so so happy with what happened there i i
called
gold long i was short goal i was short
gold going
going into late 20 2018 and then there
was this bit of a short squeeze on
comics and i saw this was happening
and then people thought you know you're
at the inversion of the yield curve
and you had um then eventually the
coronavirus which is a trigger that
nobody was expecting
um but i kept my long call
all the way through 2000 and at that
point i
i started to be becoming a bit more
skeptical i'll tell you why
there are more forces at play in the
gold market than purely
financial you know the whole fiat debate
there are there are other forces at play
and one of those forces
is that idea that we were talking about
earlier the vividly good
the when it goes up it goes up a lot
because people get excited
but people bought into etfs etfs built
up
three and a half thousand tons of gold
that's as much as a year's worth of mine
supply
it's significantly higher than was the
case post 2008
2011 and 11 and
if you look at etfs so most financial
assets right when you see a drawdown in
them
you see you see you right it's it's like
they call it a random walk right you see
one update one massive down day two up
days
massive down day whatever um
that's not true in etfs etfs
they you get directional flow in etfs
um if if one day was up
statistically the next day is more
likely to be an up day
than than a down day right so that makes
gold a trending asset
and that flow has turned lower we're
seeing the 50 day moving average on the
price turning lower we're seeing the 100
turning lower i don't know i i've
i'm not winning many friends either in
the bitcoin market or in the gold market
today but i feel like um
i feel like gold you know gold's going
to test the low 1700s
um and maybe 15. yeah
i tend to think that uh gold is not
gonna have as great of a run as bitcoin
obviously but uh
i i also tend to think that people are
underestimating
uh this idea that an entire generation
of people are basically dropping gold
and gonna buy bitcoin
uh whether they should or not is up for
debate but they're gonna do it
uh they're already starting to do it and
uh and i also think what becomes really
interesting
is uh this idea that you know bitcoin's
market cap today at 350 billion
give or take uh and gold sitting at
eight nine trillion
uh those are gonna flip and not
necessarily just because bitcoin's gonna
appreciate a bunch in kind of eclipse
gold's market cap
uh but i also think gold's gonna help it
out by having a contraction in that
market cap
you know over some period of time and it
might not be significant but but i
definitely do think we're going to see
that capital shift
uh and it's just the classic you know
when when an idea's time has come
uh there's not going to be any stopping
it and i think that it's just captured
the mind of an entire generation
never fight youth because they're going
to outlive you
you know that's honestly that's my
philosophy now i'm like if the young
people are going to do something
i mean i'm going to be old and dead and
they're still going to be doing it and
telling them not to do it's pointless
um so i honestly i think so i think i
think you're right i think
eventually something like bitcoin
becomes
this store of value for
the internet generation or the you know
but but but all of our assets are
digital why should our stores of wealth
and bitcoin has proven that it is not
going away
so yeah i'm completely on board with
that idea
i uh i couldn't believe any more than uh
than you uh
all right let's get into uh the uh kind
of final questions that's the same two
questions to everyone before i wrap up
and you'll get to ask me one question to
end it
uh the first is what's the most
important book that you've ever read
gosh jonathan livingston seagull
why that one so so
the book comes in two parts people it
was a book that i read when i was 18 and
it was it was
it changed my life right the book comes
in two parts the first
the first half says that
the purpose of life is to seek
perfection
and the second half is that the perfect
thing to search for
is love or to to perfectly love
um a lot yeah and and uh
so funny i was um i was playing tennis
with my kids the other day
and uh i um started raining
and there was a homeless guy sitting
under a bit of shelter and we went and
you know found shelter with his homeless
guy and he had this book it's like two
weeks ago you had this
jonathan livingston seagull lying there
and i was like it was just such a
flashback to this moment when i read in
my youth
anyway thanks for that question i really
enjoyed answering it
i love that story uh aliens are you a
believer or a non-believer
wow
aliens among us know but the universe is
so big how can you not they've got
if there's not something out there by
god are we special
right you know that tends to be my fault
yeah did you see did you see um elon
musk's uh tweet the other day about the
great filter
right that really got me thinking anyway
i loved it uh yeah that's uh
i there's gotta be life out there for
sure
uh you could ask me one question to
finish up what do you got for me
if you couldn't invest in
cryptocurrencies where would you put
your money
so my whole investment philosophy is
basically go to
the edges of society and uh find the
contrarian ideas that are going to
become consensus ideas and so pretty
much
uh i hold very few traditional assets i
own no public stocks other than gbtc in
a retirement account
i hold a little bit of real estate but
nothing that's really you know
significant
uh pretty much everything is in bitcoin
and in early stage startups and i think
the the thought process
uh somebody who's a very well-known
angel investor once told me he said look
80
of his net worth is in uh early stage
startups and the way he thinks about it
is he's basically went out and found the
most creative
uh smartest ambitious teams that he
possibly could
and he's given them money and tasked
them with growing his wealth
and so i tend to think that that uh that
philosophy aligns a lot with me
um and it's just this idea of looking
for
highly asymmetric type payoffs right uh
i'm a young guy i could take the risk
and
i tend to think that's a a pretty strong
way to invest so
it would either be just more early stage
startup investing uh or maybe i'd focus
on a specific sector that's uh
contrarian today but likely to become
consensus over time
can i ask you another question can i
shoot okay
so so listen um basically i look at your
media platform and your presence and
i'm slightly awestruck by the fact that
you are able to build up this you know
because you have a loyal informed um
intelligent audience that are that are
you know highly engaged
and you did it without the backing of
a media name which you know it's one
thing to to to to get a couple
you know a few twitter followers if you
if you've got the backing of the bbc or
bloomberg or whatever
it's another thing to do it all off your
own back what's the secret of your
success man
yeah i don't know necessarily uh if
there's some secret right it's just
years and years of doing the same thing
consistently
uh and i also think the the one thing
that helps me is
um you know there's a lot of people who
create content on the internet there's
very few people who also at the same
time
uh are investing you know hundreds of
millions of dollars into
companies and and cryptocurrencies etc
and so i always tell people like it's
if you're just creating content on the
internet you've got no substance to back
it up and basically you're no different
than the talking head on television
right because they're doing the same
thing they're sharing their opinion
they're creating content
but they've no kind of skin in the game
i think for me
having that substance and skin in the
game uh and then having you know some
pretty early success there where
uh a couple of companies i invested in
very early in our life cycle end up
being worth over a billion dollars and
kind of all of that uh lends legitimacy
to
what i think now again i'm wrong all the
time right just like everybody else
uh but i do think that that stuff kind
of helps um and it replaces the need to
have the backing of a media organization
because you basically have the backing
of
um you know kind of the investment
activities and so right right you know
i'm figuring out alongside everybody
else but uh uh so far so good
yeah well you're doing it faster than
most i think
thank you so much uh where can we send
people to find you on the internet or
find uh more of your work hey man um
just being on here is fantastic for me
um
they can find me on twitter i'm at ed
van der walt
it's not the easiest surname to remember
but i'm i'm ed van der walt
if they want to look me up um yeah
that'd be great
thank you listen thank you for taking
the time to do this i'm uh
i'm excited that we've got you on the uh
on the bitcoin train now so keep up uh
keep up the good work and i'll have to
do this again in the future
thank you